no one cares about your story they care
about their story and if they can see
themselves in your story then they will
care about your story this man's an
author he's an entrepreneur he's a
fashion designer he's also an expert in
communication has a brand new book
coming out wiwin mcmanis irn mcmanis
wiwin mcmanis what's up man our greatest
enemy is not taking care of our inner
world the only real limitations that
will ever hold us back are within our
own mental structures storytelling is
almost as important as living a story
wealth power our success they're all
wonderful outcomes I don't want to
diminish them they're just terrible
intentions you find a unique way to
solve a problem that everyone has it's
going to revolutionize
everything so what are some of the
biggest mistakes that content creators
make what does it take to become an
alltime Communicator what are the tips
for being a better Communicator for
reaching more people for building a
stronger brand today this is a very
special episode of the think media
podcast and our Our Guest is Irwin
mcmanis he's a renowned life architect
award-winning author and artist over 1
million books sold including his recent
new book mind shift now I've been a fan
of Irwin for years he's the pastor of
Mosaic Church and I love his pioneering
Spirit he's one of the greatest
communicators and we're going to learn a
lot of insights that are practical for
business owners content creators and
anybody that wants to get their message
to more people and so stick around until
the end of this episode irn how are you
doing I'm doing so good man I'm so
excited to be here with you man I'm so
fired up and so grateful for just your
impact on the world but if we start off
with like just like a bite-sized Tac
tactical thing to get right to it
communicating mistakes what are some of
the biggest mistakes that communicators
make maybe they turn on a zoom call they
start their video they start their
Instagram live stream their YouTube
video and as a alltime communicator you
probably are like you could fix this you
could fix that with just a small tweak
what are some of those I think the first
thing is they need to know their first
sentence and I think a lot of times what
happens they start and they ramble
around for a few minutes and they try to
find their own bearings in the process
like last week um I did a talk and the
first thing I said is you will be
defined by your limits the limits you
accept and the ones you reject and so I
wanted that opening line that opening
sentence to clarify and in a sense
divide and force people to begin to
think that through that opening sentence
is everything wow okay what how about
another one if someone's making a
mistake you see it you're like oh that
maybe undercut your message you were
delivering a message but I lost trust
there for you or maybe you lost audience
yeah I think it's not tactical it's more
in in the realm of essence I think
really the biggest mistake communicators
make is um getting ahead of themselves
wanting to be known for speaking rather
than being known for what they have to
say I think it's really important to be
aware of what you actually have to say
because if you go past what you know you
start using cliches you start mirroring
and echoing other people and The
Listener can read right through it and
you think you're saying something really
profound and compelling but they've
heard it a thousand times before and so
I actually think the most important
thing isn't tactical it's more essential
stay within the realm of your actual
learning and expertise and build on that
and then if you feel like you need more
to say go live a bigger life go gain
more experience gain more knowledge go
to the tough stuff and then you'll have
more to say and you will be more
interesting then man I like you
mentioned the word essence and one of
the things that you pioneered kind of a
proprietary framework something you
discovered I love that that sounds so
epic um is the seven dominant
communication frequencies yes nobody
else teaches this no this is absolutely
incredible um what are the seven
dominant communication frequencies and
why do they matter yeah I have to say I
I came together with this uh framework
because of something Aon asked me to do
we have a a master class called The Art
of communication and he asked me to do a
15minute giveaway he goes could you just
create something then you know we could
just give away to the masses and I spent
the weekend just diving deep and I
couldn't sleep for three or four days I
was literally in cold sweats and I just
started mapping out these seven
frequencies of communication it was 340
years of studying human communication
and just filtering it down to what are
the essential frequenc from which not
only do we speak but do we hear and so I
mapped out seven of them at first I had
five and then I had six and then I knew
something was missing and ironically the
frequency I saw last was my own and I
think that's true for all of us and
that's why processes like this are
really important we can identify other
people's but a lot of times we're blind
to our own so here they are there is the
motivator the Challenger the commander
the Healer the professor The Seer and
the maven and they may not mean anything
when you first hear the words uh but we
um we see this every day if you look at
Instagram or Tik Tok you know I can't
believe I'm 65 now I'm on Tik Tok you
know it's this is this is what's
happened to my life and uh what you'll
hear so often are people who have a
motivator frequency and they never say
anything negative they never really call
you out they don't really challenge you
but they are always inspiring you you
always feel encouraged by them you
always feel like you you matter and that
you have value and one of the people
that I know um John Gordon he's written
like 24 books you know he he focuses on
positive mental um you know structures
and he is a motivator through and
through and that's why he speaks to
college teams and pro teams and to all
the sports teams because when he speaks
he's always motivating you he's trying
to infuse belief in yourself and he's
trying to bring energy into the room and
then just slightly off of motivated but
very different it's a challenger a lot
of times when you're listening on
Instagram you listen to someone and
they're telling you you know you need to
do more you know and you need to pay the
price you owe you and the moment you
hear that frequency that's the
Challenger that's the person who thinks
their job is to wake you up and call you
out and slap you around so that you can
finally find the courage to live the
life that you were created to live then
you have the commander which is a little
bit different and and you can think of
quite a few Challengers by the way like
I think like Ben Newman is a challenger
if you ever listen to the band and David
Goggins yeah David Goggins totally you
know a challenger and and hip-hop
preacher I don't and uh Eric Thomas yeah
totally a challenger then you have the
commander commander is the person who
somehow earns almost instantaneous
Authority and they tell you what to do
they don't ask you what to do they don't
recommend what to do uh they tell you
what to do my wife Kim is a commander
I'm married for 40 years to a commander
and my wife doesn't know how to request
she only knows how to command and I've
even told her sometimes when she's going
on stage hey just ask him to do this and
the moment she gets up there she goes
everyone do this and what's crazy is
everyone does it she has so much
inherent Authority that the commander
frequency just comes up naturally for
her when someone tries to use it that
doesn't have it they can come across
like a
dictator and or that becomes like the
shadow frequency there's also the the
Healer the person whose frequency is
always focused on your Brokenness always
focused on on the pain or the trauma
you've gone through U my my friend LS
house complete healer frequency I I I
asked him one time why is your podcast
called the what the uh the summit of
greatness and um but it's really all
about healing and he goes no you're
absolutely right and for him you'll
you'll only achieve your greatness if
you deal with your inner wounds if you
deal with your pain if you find the
healing you need and that frequency uh
is is this powerful frequency where you
don't even understand what's going on
but that person understands you and they
understand your pain and they're almost
breaking open all this hidden trauma and
you're finding healing in their voice
there's also the professor the person
who believes that all change happens
through knowledge and I I have a a
friend who's supposed to have I think
the highest IQ in the world and he's
completely like a professor he believes
that everything is data in fact he
called me one time saying what what do
you mean not everything is data and he
was really upset with me because he
heard the seven frequencies yeah and he
goes no every frequency is about data
and I go no your your frequency is about
data and you read every frequency
through it a professor believes that
knowledge is power that the transference
of information the transference of facts
that's actually the frequency that
changes the world and then there's the
Seer frequency that Visionary that
person that when you're in the room with
them it's not about buying into their
Vision that's not the frequency's power
the power of a sear frequency is you
start erasing the boundaries of your own
limitations you start seeing a bigger
life for you a bigger world for you a
bigger future for yourself and all of a
sudden their Vision translates into your
inner world and you begin to have a
bigger vision for your life and then the
seventh frequency is is the maven and
this is uh the most rare and maybe the
most uh
ineffective in some ways uh the maven
frequency is the person who um violates
your view of reality they they're you're
not even sure what they're saying is
right or true but you're kind of sure
it's offensive and uh and but it's not
offensive on an interpersonal level it's
offensive in terms of your view of truth
of what's real of what's right and a
maven is usually a person who doesn't
think outside of the box they don't know
how to think inside of the box and so
when they're being asked you know what
do you do to be inventive or creative
they don't really understand that
because they don't see life from the
same vantage point and and I think this
frequency is a really important
frequency because it informs the other
frequencies but doesn't always have as
much of an impact as the other
frequencies
man that's so fascinating and and that's
the fastest summary I've ever given in
my life that was amazing you just broke
through all seven question for the
listeners is what is your frequency
because is your your primary frequency
or your current frequency is kind of
like a superpower do you want to play to
your strength do you want to double down
on your frequency yes and yes plus
because this is not based on a fixed
mindset I think that I I've studied
psychological assessments for probably
40 years I have a degree in Psychology
and philosophy and I started studying
abnormal psychology and and going
through every single test and assessment
and the problem is that most people have
a view that it's like a fixed structure
and so if you do something like the
Myers Briggs if you're familiar with it
then you are an entp or you are an isfj
and that's who you are for all of your
life and in the same thing like with the
strain finder you have five signature
strains and those stengths are your
stengths Forever This is not like that
this this is a
dynamic um view of human communication
you have a core frequency and if you
develop your communication um essence
you can actually have a cluster of
frequencies and the goal here is to be
able to access all snn frequencies
whenever you need them in life because
even let's say my number seven is
commander and my people who know me are
surprised you have they ranked uh seven
is the lowest for you Commander is my
lowest one got it it's the fre I will
least likely tap into
unconsciously so I have to tap into it
consciously I never move into Commander
by Instinct out of Intuition or out of
my Essence but if there's a fire you
better access that Commander frequency
and you better step into that inherent
Authority where everyone listens to you
and doesn't question so they can
actually all live and so there are
different times in your life you need to
be able to access all the different
frequencies at some level and so what I
try to help people do is find your
primary core frequency and then identify
the cluster of two or three that are
most accessible to you that are the
natural cluster and and then to begin to
work your way out from there and so it's
also a good question to ask what
frequency does this situation demand
that's right so perhaps maybe you're not
usually data but if you're going to
prove a point that needs data then you
need to tap into that that's right and
the challenge though is that most people
early on in their communication Journey
aren't nuanced enough or pliable enough
to adapt to the audience or to the needs
of the audience and that's why sometimes
you you bring a certain speaker in for a
certain need and you know if you bring
this speaker in for this other need
they're not going to effectively
accomplish that and you know I have a
bunch of friends and and I should leave
them nameless but you know it I was in
this room with guys like Ed milet and
John Gordon and all these different guys
and they're all talking about who's the
greatest Communicator right you know
because they're not competitive at all
right and you who's the greatest
Communicator in the world and and one of
the things you know that we began to lay
out is maybe it's not who's the best
communicator but who's the right
Communicator for this moment for this
people if people need penicillin it
doesn't really matter if like your
message cures something else sure they
need what they need in that moment
highlevel communicators can read an
audience really fast
and move toward the frequency that's
needed in that moment talking about from
your Vantage Point what frequency is the
primary strength of a couple characters
people would know how about
Oprah I think Oprah Is A Healer I think
that's her dominant frequency from my
observation yeah and that she works from
this interesting mix of of a Healer
motivator she wants to inspire people
she wants to elevate people but she
really wants to heal people and connects
at a deep level I think whenever you're
in a conversation with Oprah you're
watching therapy happen and and you have
all these you know top level celebrities
and stars and all of a sudden they're in
a therapeutic session with her and it's
not even by what she says it's by what
she asks and how she pulls things out of
you and all of a sudden you're having
all these epiphanies about your own need
for healing and growth and development
so I would put her in the Healer
category what do you think about Dr Phil
I think Dr Phil is um a commander and a
professor most high communicators have a
blend of two uh but Dr Phil is
definitely a commander he sees himself
as the principal Authority and he's
right to tell you what to do yep it's
sort of like Dave Ramsey I think Dave
Ramsey is a commander he doesn't give
you options for how you should um manage
your money he tells you what to do
gotcha and and he comes from and he
comes from a core Authority base and
people do exactly what he says yes
that's how you know his frequency works
because he has people all over the world
who he's never seen face to face who
follow step by step everything he says
because of the inherent power of His
Commander frequency how about Donald
Trump
that's you know without being political
yeah okay um all seven frequencies have
Shadow frequencies and so when a person
is operating from um an
inherent energy that's pulling toward
themselves rather than toward others you
begin to experience the shadow frequency
and so I I think that Donald Trump
probably is a commander but what people
experience is a shadow frequency which
is a
dictator and and so when you watch him
at his best you know because I think
he's had Great Moments yeah um you watch
a person with clear command no question
about his Direction his authority he
believes that your operational
relationship is to do what he tells you
that's how you know he's a commander
yeah and then when he's in a shadow
frequen quency it becomes dictatorial
and he has in a sense of Vendetta and or
becomes angry feels betrayed yeah
because when you have a commander
frequency and you're working from the
shadow if someone doesn't do what you
tell them they've betrayed
you rather than thinking oh they
disagreed with me yeah can you see the
difference oh incredibly powerful and
and it's a deep conversation to improve
our skills as communicators to now see
okay what is our primary frequency how
can we velop all of the frequencies but
now you're introducing this concept of
the Shadow frequencies one of the things
I actually heard you mention was you
were watching the show succession now we
also both discovered that we're both
fans of the show even though we're not
allowed to say we are even though we're
not allowed to say we are because it's
it's obviously it's kind of it's pretty
intense show you could even call it kind
of more dark and that was one of the
Revelation it it has a seediness to it
it has a seediness to it you you were
like I know all these frequenc
but why am I not quite seeing in the
show and then you realized well was the
shadow so go a little bit deeper into
that what happened is we have this
Learning Community called The Arena and
so I asked the arena give me the shows
that you'd like for me to break down and
they all gave me two shows friends and
secession could you have two polar
opposite shows in the whole world as far
as Joy positivity humor versus like
betrayal you know cut your throat to the
top like so I wasn't really interested
in doing friends yeah so thought I've
watched all of s session I am a huge fan
yeah and we talk about the show all the
time in LA so I thought okay I'm going
to I'm going to break down the seven
frequencies there seven or eight major
characters and I I felt um traumatized
when I looked at it I couldn't find a
single one of the frequencies yeah and
there's nothing like being the person
who designed a particular Paradigm and
then to find it
not detectable it's missing completely
and so I had a panic attack is the
Paradigm broken yes is the question but
well then I had this in her thought I
thought check the
Shadows which had not occurred to me at
first and so the moment I looked at the
Shadows all the characters started
popping out and and I I wrote some of
them down here because and you know this
is really more for fun this is not
scientific in any way right and so I I
put down okay Logan he's the commander
but he what all you see is the dictator
yes and Kendall I think Kendall's a Seer
he's actually a Visionary but because
it's only a shadow you see the
perfectionist who's always crushed
because he can he can never meet up to
his own expectations or anyone else's
you have shiff who's a challenger but
all you see is their Shadow so she's the
manipulator then you have uh Roman who's
the motivator he just wants to make
people happy you know and uh and because
his shadow is dominant he's a
performer and then you have Connor who
marries is a prostitute right that is
the the shadow of a Healer because he it
becomes the guru and he wants to be
president of the United States he wants
the whole world to follow him because he
believes he's the source of healing for
everyone and that's the the shadow of
the Healer the guru is the shadow of the
Healer yeah because it's not that I can
help you find Healing I am the source of
healing you need me to be healed and
that's the the Nuance danger and even in
Cults wow you have Tom and Tom I think
is a professor who then actually is his
shadow is he's a
micromanager and and then you have Greg
and Greg is the one I really struggled
with so he he's the one is my furthest
leap because I think I think Greg is the
maven and that's why you can't see him
and but his shadow is you know is that
uh he's a pessimist he's always thinking
something bad's going to happen to him
or you know or something bad is going to
happen uh he's not going to get what he
deserves or and and but I think Greg was
um if there had been another season I
think Greg would be the one who just
starts elevating yeah unexpectedly wow
and so what is the encouragement for
communicators for the heart development
mind development to be powerful
communicators to protect and Guard from
drifting into this ditch of being a
manipulator being a dictator and we want
to improve our content but of course
this going to affect everything around
us our relationships our family for
those building teams for uh church
leaders based leaders culture this can
creep into every Arena absolutely and
one of the things that I think I really
struggled with is you know I grew up
irreligious and um and then when I
became a person of faith and became a
follower of Jesus I didn't resonate with
the dominant voices that we're
expressing now a belief I had and it was
really really difficult for me and then
when you turn on you know religious
television you've got manipulator after
after manipulator after manipulator
after Guru after Guru after performer
after performer and frankly all I saw
were Shadow frequencies wow and it
really was incredibly disturbing to me
and so I I think this is really
important because unless you decide to
become your authentic self you're always
going to be working from the shadow one
stage and then I think we have to give
ourselves a little Grace where we go
back and forth sometimes because of
insecurity and you know because of you
know of self-doubt so you can be on
stage and you're really the motivator
and you're trying to encourage every
you're trying to infuse life and hope
and um in people but then suddenly you
become really self-aware do they like me
how's my talk going the moment you're in
that selft talk on stage now you're
moving into your Shadow so then you
start performing and you want to perform
because you want to make sure that the
crowd loves you yeah and you know and so
it can be really really um a dynamic
process of going okay I know I have this
performer Instinct in me yes and what I
want to do when I walk on that platform
is not care about what people think
about me but what I think about them yes
not whether the audience is going to
love me but whether I'm going to love
them and one of the things I love is we
just did this conference of the arena
live in LA and right before you walk up
on the stage uh Aaron and his team put
down um this
matters so that right before you walk up
you see those two words it's really
trying to help the speaker move out of
themselves mhm so they see themselves as
a servant to the realm Y and that's the
key the way you can know about uh
whether you're moving in in a shadow of
your using in the sense that the light
of that of that frequency is are you
focused on serving or you focused on
receiving and
benefiting and and I think we can all
struggle we can all struggle with that
man so powerful um I want to ask who are
some Modern communicators that you think
we can learn from in culture and music
in media so so if we're just looking to
extrapolate tips and then anchoring back
in that everybody listening to this
wants to make better content they want
to reach people more through video
specifically YouTube but across
platforms what are some of the
observations you're seeing in modern
communication that are maybe principles
we could apply to our day-to-day content
creation well one I think we're having a
revolution of
communication I uh what Instagram and
Tik Tok and the development of social
media has done is it has heightened
value of the ability to communicate
quickly and uh in in a really succinct
and Powerful way Twitter did that with
writing when you can only have 140
characters for me it was like a dream
come true I I love condensing and
finding a way to put something really
profound in a capsule that explodes so
when everyone complaining about the
words I'm like no this is beautiful it's
a tiny canvas have you ever seen the
modal Lisa it's it's so small I I took
my daughter to live because she wanted
to see it so badly when I walked up and
I saw how small it was like what did
dein she you R out of canvas what's the
deal and I thought Mariah would be so
disappointed because she was maybe 10
years old and she stood there and it was
quiet she never said a word and minutes
went by and finally she said I could
stand her stand here and look at her all
day long and I realized that if you have
true genius you just don't really need
that large of a canvas I think that's
the way it should be with language with
words and with communication if you
really have something to say then
harness the ability to say it in such a
way that the fewer the words the more
powerful and that's the thing I would
say to most people on social media Mo
most people trying to develop their
message if it takes you too long to say
it you don't understand it yet
storytelling is crucial to business
success that's a quote from Entrepreneur
magazine um but I hear about
storytelling you're an alltime
Storyteller you're as a communicator at
Mosaic Church you are often telling
stories Weekly right and tying it into
your content yet I feel like it's also
kind of a buzzword there's all kinds of
people like oh storytelling storytelling
but you're like okay so what does that
mean
practically how do I actually Implement
that so why do you think storytelling
matters and how do you actually finding
craft stories that we could weave into
our content what are some practical tips
storytelling is almost as important as
living
story and I think the problem is that
we're moving people right to
storytelling rather than story
living the reason I can tell a lot of
stories is because I live a lot of life
and I and I I remember oh probably 15
years ago I mean can you imagine being
my wife having to listen to me speak for
so many decades right it's just brutal
and she came up to me one day and she
said you told the same
story and when she said that she was
saying a lot
and I think I got on a plane and I went
somewhere and began to experience life
again because what I heard her say was
you need to live something new something
fresh something
real and the reason I can tell 10,000
Stories is I've lived 10,000 lives and
and I I I think a part of the problem is
that if you're having to borrow stories
from people you're also borrowing lives
rather than living one and so in every
book I write there might be one or two
minor exceptions but I never write a
story unless I've actually encountered
that person or had an experience related
to it and that way every story in my
books are not the result of research
they're result of living and so I I'm
absolutely convinced the storytelling
does shape the future I think 30 years
ago I wrote in my first book that
whoever tells the best story shapes the
culture and and one of things that would
always frustrate me is that the truth
trapped in a bad story will never win
over a lie told in a great story and we
see that even today when we're dealing
with the conflicts in Israel and
Palestine everyone's working to get the
stories out and people don't even look
at the facts they just get captured by a
story and that story for them becomes
reality and that's why stories are so
important the entire of human history is
transported by stories and nothing else
it's the stories that we told each other
through the Roman Empire and the
Egyptian Empire it's stories we've told
ourselves through Western history and
Eastern history those stories shape us
and they carry us and they Define us and
so really what we need to do is first
live a great story then tell that story
well and in that story the values and
principles that you want to pass on will
transfer from you to someone else for
The Listener
who maybe is digging to see what story
have I lived but as they dig they
discover well I did overcome stage four
cancer well I did my wife and I were on
the verge of divorce but we made it work
and now we've built a strong marriage
and we want to help others do it but I
was overweight and now I'm fit and I'm
energetic when I think about the
creators listening to this they figured
out how to succeed in real estate and
now they teach others how to do it a lot
of Educators but maybe the block for
them is but how do I package it and tell
it because some people when they tell a
story they're like well if I'm going to
communicate this thing I'm going to need
three hours where you're like well
should it be 3 hours in your 12 minute
YouTube video how do I consolidate it is
there any basic framework when you think
about distilling a story and then
putting into it a piece of your
communication yeah it's a brutal one and
um and I know I've even got negative
push back on this okay and but I'm gonna
say the way I've said it no one cares
about your story okay they care about
their story and if they can see
themselves in your story then they will
care about your story but if if all they
can see is you in your story they won't
care about your story so the key to
crafting a great story is making it
profoundly human where everyone can see
themselves in it so powerful so you
coach pastors uh artists creatives what
are the biggest blockers that hinder
them from producing their best work
first of all I thought it was
interesting you said I coach pastors I
don't get to coach pastors very much
okay more entrepreneurs artists and
creatives yeah I'm going I try yeah and
um I think actually
the greatest hindrance is the fear of
other people's opinions wow and if we
could just stop living a life of
obligation and start living a life of
intention it would change everything if
we could begin to tell our story from
what is true to us without factoring in
how will other people feel about it
you're going to tell the most powerful
story and if no one's offended by your
story no one is transformed by your
story either and so sometimes I know for
me fact I think it was like 30 years ago
somebody came up to me and they said how
do you do it I go do what I go how do
you not care about all the negative
input you get all the negative feedback
all the hate I go what made you think I
don't care I care so much I am so
profoundly empathetic all those things
really hurt me I just don't let it
Define me and I don't let it set my
course just because you don't let them
redirect you doesn't mean it doesn't
affect you I felt every one of those
stings in my life yeah I just had to
decide do I live for the acceptance of
others or do I live out my own
uniqueness and sense of intention wow
that's so powerful you know when I hear
you say that it seems obvious to me but
I would imagine listeners would think
why would you get push back why would
you get negative feedback why would you
get
critics and go a little bit deeper on on
that a little bit how
you as a maven have continued to Pioneer
when maybe you don't feel supported or
when you are not being supported or when
because we all want our messages to be
accepted that's like seems to be the
definition of success especially if I'm
going to monetize views I'm going to
monetize um and so before you're seeing
that happen yeah process that a little
bit for those dealing with negativity
themselves or um that that are convicted
on their message but just feel like it's
not resonating or getting the support to
answer that I can't avoid the actual
context in which I was in right before
we came in Sean Aaron was saying to me
um Dad you are so much more accepted in
this business space than you ever were
in like the ministry space go in the
business space yeah there's friction we
were literally having this conversation
going you know why did you always choose
the path of most resistance and because
that would in many ways describe
American
Christianity and so um
I didn't know one you're not necessarily
aware that you're a maven you just think
that um you see the world the way
everyone sees the world it just takes a
little while before you realize that no
one else sees the world the way you're
seeing it right now and so early on when
I became a person of faith I was so
bored in church so it wasn't like a
highly Noble motivation I just didn't
want to fall asleep because now I
believe in Jesus and I have to go to
church and my wife man she's like you
don't miss church and and I you know I'm
like you know I don't want to miss
church but I'm okay if I wanted to go
you know skiing or something else right
you know and and I I'm still faithful
and I still love God everything like
that but Kim's not like that yeah so I'm
in church every Sunday and I'm falling
asleep I can't even stay awake and she'd
get mad at me wake up wake up and that's
even when I was the speaker and I said
honey I didn't grow up in church so I
don't have the muscle that can resist
boredom and so then when I started
having influence and started deciding
that I'm supposed to affect the space I
started bringing radical changes that I
did not know would have so much
resistance to me they're obvious things
architecture either inspires or it it
like swallows up inspiration it can
architecture can be boring or
architecture can be beautiful so I
started working on all the architecture
and changing the designs and taking out
pews and and and realizing Christians
end up putting stacked chairs the exact
same line as pews and I go what is wrong
with us and I started using stand-up
comedy and and drama and film and
editing films and using them on Sundays
and um and you know just having people
painting throughout the building and all
this made people angry I'm like how does
this make people angry we're just
creating Beauty and Artistry and wonder
and U and and yeah I mean I did a few
things that might have been mildly
unorthodox and uh and then we became
incredibly diverse and it was a
homogeneous church and now it's Asian
Latino African-American white it's like
it just became an incredible blend
people get upset about that and then
people with earrings in their faces
started showing up on stage you know
because I had a band and and uh and and
they got kind of wild and all these
people are like all tatted up and
everything and i' had people telling me
no more people with earrings in their
faces on stage and I'm like but their
heart's awesome like you know I'd rather
have a great heart with lots of earrings
in the face than your face without
earrings and that level of judgmentalism
and so maybe I didn't always like handle
it the right way but all these changes
brought criticism at every step along
the way even by the way you you've said
Mosaic Church several times because
that's what we do whenever we have faith
but it's not called Mosaic Church it's
just Mosaic I received so much backlash
Are you ashamed of the church kind of
but um but it wasn't why I took the word
Church off it's just Mosaic yeah and the
reason I called it just Mosaic is
because I didn't want it to feel like
it's a place just for Christians I want
it to be a place for anyone who is
trying to find meaning in life and you
put Church on things because you want
Christians to know this is where you
belong I said no we're not going to do
that I don't wear a shirt that says
human I am human and I expect people to
figure that out and we're not going to
put a sign this as Church we're going to
create this beautiful community and let
people figure it out and so there's a
lot of things I did like that that
created so much resistance even the
language for a lot of years I spoke
using the children's Bible
and my wife would sayou offending
people's intelligence I said they need
to be offended because they think that
Christianity is um an academic
intellectual Pursuit and it's a human
Pursuit and Jesus spoke to little
children and so if I can't communicate
the most important message in the world
in a way that a child can get it I don't
think I'm doing it the way Jesus would
do it wow so we just made and then of
course we moved into a nightclub that
Prince owned which probably created a
lot of Crisis this is Decades of before
this was more popular yeah I mean every
Sunday we would go in there and we use
double rubber gloves and clean up all
the hypmic needles and all the condoms
and move all the mattresses where people
were having sex all over the room and
fixing commodes that were just
overflowing with vomit and and this was
our Sunday space wow and we would get
shut down by the police sometimes
because the parties were so wild that
they would punish us for the club's
activity on Saturday night and no one
thought we should be there and I thought
it was the perfect place for us to be
and we also moved to this club called
the Mayan that has like a a thousand
Gods carved in there and of course all
the Christians are like you can't be in
this like sacrilegious space with all
these gods in it I'm going it's the
perfect place for us to be it's where
everyone who doesn't believe in God
would go because they were here on
Saturday night partying so when I say
come to my end they go oh I know exactly
where that was I was there last night so
we we just made so many changes and the
language I stopped using
religious language and started only
using human language and we did a survey
a few years ago on Sunday Easter Sunday
and we as I asked how many of you are
atheist but you would say I'm an atheist
but if God's out there I'd be open we
had over a thousand adults say I'm an
atheist but if God was out there I want
to know and I think that's the
difference with Mosaic and Christians
would say it doesn't feel like church
because we're
outnumbered and I just love the fact
that we were always Reinventing
recreating but it wasn't because I was
trying to do
something um
offensive I I think when you're a maven
frequency you're also trying to figure
out how do I reach the other mavens in
the
world and I realized there were a lot of
people who saw the world the way I did
and they're spread across the world but
the conversation about God has never
been communicated in their frequency wow
and so they were not rejecting God they
were rejecting the frequency that did
not communicate to them and so I
understood most people will not resonate
with the way I created a community in
the way I communicate but that's okay
because I really wanted to give my life
to the top 5% of innovators and
intuitives and Pioneers and
entrepreneurs and creators because if
someone doesn't speak on their frequency
they're going to think that God is not
speaking to them there's so many nuggets
in there and I also think it's
empowering it's always inspir like
courage is transferable I think the
spirit of innovation is like it's
transferable and just to see your
conviction to go against the grain to do
something different it's one of the
freshest things we need as content
creators when everyone's echoing and
copying the same things how can we
Pioneer and follow that Maven
inspiration you know one of the things
that you especially have expertise in
because you coach high level the top
five percentage you said after
implementing the right skills the right
tips the right perseverance content
creators influen eventually experience
massive success and it's actually wild
what's happening in this world ever
since Justin Bieber gets discovered on
YouTube um and and has insane amounts of
Fame at such a young age now I would
argue that that's more common in the
last decade and two decades of course
than ever before in human history these
platforms give people of all ages though
the chance of all of a sudden I was
unknown and now I've got fame or I've
got money or I've got opport I've got
people sliding into my DMs Proverbs 423
says above all else guard your heart for
everything you do flows from it what
advice do you have for those that want
to be building a life that's built to
last once they start experiencing
massive success once now there are
different things coming their way
stewarding success is crushing a lot of
content
creators how can we guard against that I
think there's a couple things I'd like
to maybe highlight one is that uh
Fame wealth power success they're all
wonderful outcomes I don't want to
diminish them they're just terrible
intentions when you make Fame your
purpose you will collapse even if you
become famous because you'll never be
famous enough because it's an elusive
endgame if you make wealth your purpose
you will collapse under the weight of
that wealth because wealth is a brutal
purpose
because you'll never be wealthy enough
and you'll always have the fear of not
having but when it's an outcome it's a
wonderful thing and I I know so many
people who had incredible wealth and
they lost it all and they would say well
I lost my purpose well that's because
your purpose was in the outcome your
purpose should be about becoming your
purpose should always be rooted in the
person you're becoming not in what you
accomplish and when your purpose is
rooted in what who you're becoming
whether you're succeed or fail that
doesn't touch your purpose it's just an
outcome differential that you can change
over time and then I think the second
thing is it's why I wrote mind shift
because I I I realized even last night I
was doing this book signing at uh the
Grove at Barn Noble in LA and sometimes
you explain something and you see it for
the first time and I realize that I've
been in three major phases of My Life as
a mentor and the first I spent it with
the urban poor I worked with gangbangers
cartels people who are incredibly
impoverished and I went with I went in
with a very idealistic view of humanity
I thought if I can just remove the
obstacles that are keeping them trapped
in poverty they all they will all just
rise up that I was wrong there were
internal structures of failure in their
mental thinking the mental constructs
their mental mind mindsets that actually
held them back and then I thought okay
that's why the poor are being held back
so if I can change their mental
structures if I can give them a mind
shift I can move him out of poverty
that's 10 years then I moved to LA and
started working with artists creatives
you know the the most intuitive people
in the world the more most creative
people in the world and I thought
they're going to be different and I
realized oh my gosh they have the same
mental structure issues that the poor
had and even though they're hyper
creative and Hyper artistic and no
matter how much celebrity they gain
they're still struggling with depression
they're still struggling with a lack of
value they're still struggling with
identity issues they are still
struggling with the exact same NE netive
structures that the people trapped in
poverty war that was the next 20 years
of my life and then I started working
with people who were from the 100
million to the billions and I thought
okay it's gonna be different here I
gotta find a new game plan right you
know I need I need a new skill set for
my advising coaching and it didn't take
five minutes before I realized oh my
gosh this guy has a billion dollars he
has the exact same mental structures as
the creative in the exact same mental
structures as the guy who's poor and if
they don't change those mental
structures they're going to be rich and
miserable they're going to have billions
and die alone they're not going to have
any friendships they're going to wake up
every day with a sense of sadness and
depression and so I wrote mind shift
because I realized that most people have
strategies to deal with failure but very
few people have strategies for dealing
with success and while some of us may
fall under the weight of failure most of
us who are listening are going to
collapse under the weight of success and
we don't plan for Success we think we do
but we don't we don't sit down and go
what kind of human being do I need to be
to carry 100 million what kind of human
being do I need to be to lose 100
million and then get back up and start
all over again because I have several
friends who have done that what kind of
mental structures do I need if I I had I
met with a guy my first meeting with him
I got an email would you meet with this
guy and I said sure Friday coffee I
didn't know he lived in New York he
jumped on a plane came and met me for
coffee had lost $2 billion
from his company and 55 million from his
personal account and had a heart attack
got up 270 pounds his marriage was in
Ruins and I always get people oftentimes
at that stage of the game and was really
facing some tremendous issues and I
realized he's struggling with the same
need for a mind shift that the gang
banger was dealing with and that highly
successful creative artist who everyone
sees as a celebrity was dealing with
yeah yeah and you know we've become
really great friends it's been a 5-year
journey together you know he just
settled for $4.2 billion doesn't have a
single bit of debt in his entire life
owns like 20 companies his marriage has
been healed his family is doing
fantastic wow but it's not because he
figured out how to be a better
businessman it's because he dealt with
the internal structures that would lead
to this to self-destructive Behavior
yeah our greatest enemy is not taking
care of our inner world and that's why
the opening page of the book says the
intention of this book is to destroy
internal limitations because the only
real limitations that will ever hold us
back are within our own mental
structures man it's so powerful and
can't recommend the book enough as well
mind shift um and of course we'll link
all those resources up in the
description and uh this one is a Nob
brainer no pun intended uh but it
doesn't take a genius to think like one
the book is mind shift uh I think in the
first
message at mosaic one of the aspects of
Mind shift is this aspect of innovation
and you talked about innovate Innovative
thinking like David's choice of a
slingshot can lead to breakthrough in
life's challenges what about that
biblical story speaks to Innovation and
how can we become better innovators it
does feel like on social media
podcasting video there's a lot of just
copying and echoing and at some point or
in every case that might get you
moderate success but that's never going
to change the whole Paradigm Innovation
feels like this elusive thing and I know
a major mindset of our community
everyone's already done it um there's so
much competition and it's overwhelming
there is massive opportunity but seems
like people are moving fast and so
Innovation again is kind of like another
buzzword sounds amazing how do we
actually tap into that practically and
begin to innovate as content creators I
rarely think you innovate by trying to
solve someone else's problem you usually
innovate when you're trying to solve
your own
problem because then you know you've
actually solved it and I think a lot of
times we try to Pretend We're solving
problems by creating products but they
haven't solved them in our life either I
I can tell you that all the minds in
that book solved my
problems I didn't research those I live
them and as painful as it is I thought
badly poorly wrong at every at a point
in my life where I had to make a shift
and I felt the painful transition of it
so when you talk about Innovation I
think Innovation comes from solving real
problems I I love the story of David
when he fights Goliath and and you know
usually it's a story that is there to
Advocate Faith you need to have faith
and trust in God but the reality is that
the story is so much more than that
because you know King Saul puts his
armor on David and it's too big for
David and it's clunky and David's going
to get killed if he goes to fight
Goliath the same way everyone ever
fought him and here's the crazy thing
David wasn't the best warrior if he was
going to take on the same strategy he
wasn't as talented as the guys who were
already
dead I think a lot of times we're trying
to you know you're trying to be whatever
Alex orosa you're trying to be Tony
Robbins or you're trying to be you know
Ed my lad or whoever it is or Mel
Robbins they're already better than you
they're already better than me so why
would I go to war with their armor on
what David had to do is step back and go
you know I'm a kid and I got this giant
and all these these other guys already
dead so this is the scenario I know this
approach doesn't work so I'm not going
to try the same approach and believe
somehow I can Elevate this approach a
lot of people try to be creative doing
the same thing and creativity can
optimize a particular strategy but I
have a LoveHate relationship with
creativity when I start something new
there's a creative journey to optimizing
it but you get to about 80% and you're
using using so much energy to get that
last 20% I like cutting out when I'm at
about 80% and innovating and finding a
new way to get to the next 80% easier
because I find the zero to 80 is faster
than the 80 to 100 wow so that's where
you need to begin innovating not when
you're failing but when you're slowing
down so David picks up a slingshot and
five smooth stones and it only needs
one because this Innovation was so
Dynamic that that he was able to kill
Goliath throwing a stone keeping his
distance it solved all the problems if a
giant gets too close he's going to crush
me you and uh and uh his sword weighs
more than my sword you know I'm I have a
pin and he has a sword and David kills
this giant knocks him out and after that
everyone knows how to kill a giant by
the way there's another place in the
Bible this story David takes a few
chapters later there's one verse that
says that Goliath's I think five other
brothers were also conquered but just
one verse why because once you kill a
giant it's not a story after that wow
and one of the powerful things with
Innovation is you're not necessarily
trying to solve a new problem you're
trying to solve an old problem that no
longer can be solved with an old
solution so I don't feel like everyone's
already taken up all the space you find
a unique way to solve a problem that
everyone has it's going to revolutionize
everything W and and anyone who thinks
all the space has been taken is probably
right for them but think about this
there are only 12 notes has every song
ever been that's ever going to be
written has been written no wow the most
common song in the world is I love you
there will be more songs about I love
you than any other subject that will
ever be written about why because there
is so much space if you create an innov
there are only three primary colors so
why do we have picassos why do we have
Mones why do why do we have Da
Vinci really everything that's ever been
painted should already been painted and
yet somebody can take those three
primary colors and blend them in a white
to create an endless number of color
effects and it's true in everything
they're they're only like what line
circles and squares that's it so really
architecture should have stopped 150
years ago and yet AR chitecture is that
it's Pinnacle of design and yet they're
so limited with circles triangles and
squares you can either see the
limitations as the reason why you don't
innovate or you can see those
limitations as the material from which
you must innovate I want to go a little
bit deeper you you know talking about
David eventually his son King
Solomon um here's his fact list King
Solomon he's revered as one of the
wisest and wealthiest men who ever lived
um he the son of King David and baeba he
became a king at age
20 uh his Reign is a time of peace and
prosperity for Israel he's known for
wisdom and Justice I figure I'm guessing
I don't know this ahead of time but that
he's probably one of your favorite
characters because he wrote several
books including the Bible Proverbs
Solomon Ecclesiastes but it also talks
about how he was a patron of the Arts
and the Sciences it says like he's he
wrote songs he did all this different
stuff and then of course end um the book
of uh Proverbs which is full of
wisdom I think a wi wisdom is maybe a
misunderstood term I'm curious maybe
just ranting on this whole subject when
it comes to being an innovator being a
creative what can we learn from King
Solomon what can we learn from Proverbs
and do you think that people understand
what wisdom is what is wisdom what
really is it well first of all we can
know from Solomon that you can actually
live a significant life even if you're a
trust fun
kid good point he he built speaking of
succession tying it all the way back
that's a good succession yeah and and
while his father was a man of war he
became a man of Peace So he was able to
accomplish something his father couldn't
accomplish even though there were things
that he could have never accomplish that
his father did accomplish and so I think
there's a powerfully synergistic
relationship there and and I I think we
undervalue the power of legacy of what
we can pass on from generation to
generation to generation which can be
incredible
beautiful and you know with Solomon when
he when you talk about wisdom I think at
its basic level like at its most simple
level wisdom is about connecting the
dots and it's about um understanding
cause and effect and when you look at
people who live really like foolish
lives or just make continuously dumb
decisions they have an improper
relationship between cause and effect
they think oh I can um I can make this
choice and get this
outcome and you know I remember one time
years and years ago when I was working
in this inner city project and this you
know 15-year-old girl came up to me and
Tory group and said she was pregnant and
and her first line was I don't know how
this happened to me and you know said I
think you do the problem is you didn't
think that there would be a consequence
to a choice that you couldn't
control and I remember one time I was at
this advant I had this guy he was just
jacked really athletic and I I asked him
to come up and do something for me I
said I just want you to take this ball I
want you thr as hard as you can against
this wall and he goes really are you
sure because we're inside this building
said yeah just trust me I'm I rented it
it's fine and so he takes this thing and
everybody's watching him was he was he
was the stud and he throws this ball
it's hard to get against that wall and
it exploded back off the wall and it hit
him right in the face it was like
perfect and the first thing he said is
why'd you make me do that and I said
why' I make you do what he goes you make
me hit myself I said well why didn't you
think about where the ball would go
after you threw it did you think it
would go through the wall why didn't you
throw it at an
angle because he didn't connect effect
to cause so he was in charge of the
cause but I was to blame for the effect
at the at its simal level wisdom is
connecting the dots between cause and
effect but we know life becomes so much
more complicated than that
but I've done these surveys around the
world and I've interviewed people the
wisest people in the world are rarely
the people that have the most wealth in
a person's life and usually the wisest
people in the world are rarely the
person most educated you can have wealth
and be wise and you can be educated to
be wise but it's actually more rare than
you think the wisest people that we
identify are the ones that have healthy
relationships somehow they seem to be
able to make life work and I actually
think wisdom is deeply connected to the
principle of seeing life about people
that the economy of God is
relationships and when you understand
that life will be measured by the health
of relationships look solom made a lot
of mistakes Solomon did a lot of things
wrong but you cannot have peace in the
land if you don't have the ability to
create relational health and so you had
an entire nation that was at peace
because people were not fighting against
each other
and one of the most powerful things you
know and there other layers when you go
past cause and effect the next level of
wisdom is pattern
recognition is when uh people who are
highly wise can identify the effect of
patterns I've seen this before I can I
tell you how many times I would counsel
people early in my life and and I
learned early not to tell people what to
do because one they don't do it anyway
and two if they do what you say it
doesn't work they blame it on you so I
you know I'm like
here these are your options this is
where this choice will take you this is
where this choice will take you you have
to decide which way you'll go and I
cannot tell you how many people would
choose one choice and want a different
outcome they come back 10 years later 15
years later and they'd find me and go it
turned out just like you said how did
you know and I would tell them what
because I'm from the future and so I
came back to warn you but because when
you have wisdom you're actually living
from the future in the present when you
have wisdom you do not make choices that
cost you your future for something you
can gain in the present when you have
wisdom you sacrifice the present for the
future it's deep and uh as we land the
plane I have a powerful question and
kind of ending conversation to have but
I want to encourage uh listeners that of
course there's so much more we could
cover and you want to check out Irwin's
books uh in particular mind shift we've
linked everything up in the show notes
and of course there's other um bonus
things down there that you can check out
um but as we're speaking
to content creators MH um my friend car
newoff
calls this industry knowledge workers
and he he calls it that sometimes
critics think oh what's a content
creator really doing what's an artist
really doing I'm out here you know doing
hard labor which is absolutely
respectable and truly fatiguing but many
people understand misunder understand
how fatiguing and exhausting knowledge
work is crafting messages writing books
and it feels like the
demand for Content creation for having a
great podcast and trying to research
your guests and then to come up with
original YouTube videos over and over
again and then multiply that by years
and multiply that by decades I've been
on YouTube for 16 years doing video for
20 I feel like a real OG in this space
it's about as old old as you can get it
was two years after the platform started
so um you have
lived not just you've you've lived a
great story not just telling a great
story but you've also been very prolific
over multiple decades multiple books
what are the habits and routines and
practices for not just getting lucky
once very common for Content creators
who I got viral I don't know how to
package that and repeat that what would
you encourage artists creatives
entrepreneurs for continuing to be
prolific very difficult that's one thing
to have one hit song yeah how do you
have an actual career of continual hit
songs well I do have a talk out there
somewhere on
Serendipity on how to create continuous
serendipitous
experiences and I was in Costa Rica at
this medical center and I started um
just sitting down and realizing that
that so many of things I write and
create are incredibly serendipitous like
they just come to me in an explosion and
they are magical or Supernatural or
whatever language you want to use um but
my wife has seen it for 40 years and my
family seen it I I'll walk into a coffee
shop and I'll have the whole the whole
talk I was driving through Hollywood and
I heard a voice in my head tell me um
the warrior is not ready for battle
until he has come to no peace this is
the way of the war Warrior I heard it in
my head and I told my wife oh I know my
next book I know the first line the way
of the warrior and I and it was like I
heard this Japanese voice and it was you
know konomy from the you know Last
Samurai it's like I just had these
cupidus
explosions and and so I wanted to help
people learn how to have those kind of
experiences because they're not
accidental they're the result of a
continuous practice in my life and some
of it is you um you have to have deep
EXP experiences that are constantly
challenging you those experiences that
pull you outside of your comfort zone
experiences that allow you to experience
life differently in a new and beautiful
way and um you know Aon and I had a
friend and he sent us a text I got
reservations for noma in Copenhagen for
dinner and Yin and it was like three
weeks later or two weeks later we're in
like my wife's like you're going to
dinner in Copenhagen said yes honey I'm
going to dinner in Copenhagen while you
go to Africa and build a school I'm
going to go have dinner
and we got on a plane I flew to London
he was already living in London at the
time and I just move into continuous
experiences and um and I love the fact
that people know around the world that
I'm the guy that will jump on a plane
and
fly to Tokyo or to you know North Korea
or wherever it may be and to have an an
opportunity to experience something I've
never experienced I think that's one of
the reasons I have continuous
serendipitous experiences the other one
is Imagination you have to allow your
imagination to run wild um you know I
take walks I um you know I spend an hour
or two by myself I turn off my phone and
I just dream and imagine and I press and
I I don't really tell my imagination
where to go and and I and I've read so
many books in my life that have seated
my imagination like Robert heinlin and
Isaac azof and Andre Norton all these
science fiction writers they seated my
imagination and so I just let my
imagination go wild and run crazy and
then the other thing you really have to
have is um is reflection and when you're
going through experiences and you're
expanding your imagination and you have
the space for reflection you're able to
start connecting the dots between what
you've experienced and what you imagin
and realize there's something new
Brewing you know along the way and and
that's not the whole of it but I I think
that's a good place to begin and I would
just say you know if you want to if you
want to stay generative and stay
creative um you you also have to like
intersect all that with a deep love for
someone or something that you want to
help or solve because what drives
everything inside of me is when someone
I care about is hit a wall or someone I
love is
drowning and and I can't figure out how
to help
them and it creates something in me
because it generate something deep
inside of me where all of a sudden my
imagination isn't just a playground like
I'm searching for a solution that I
can't see right now my experiences are
not just self-indulgent I'm trying to
expand my my my Humanity so that I can
know something that I could not know
before and when you're doing that you
just become a vessel and and things do
seem to almost transcendently connect to
you I cheat there's no question in my
mind I cheat I wrote one of my books the
Barbarian why in 10 hours hours I
downloaded that book so quickly when I
did the seven frequencies my wife woke
up at 5: in the morning I was in cold
sweats she goes are you okay I said I
can't stop writing like I'm hearing this
it's coming so fast and there's almost
like you feel like you're on a a brink
of of of Madness because you're trying
to solve a problem that maybe no one
else can solve and that's that's the to
me don't be focused on yourself like ask
yourself like how can I be a vessel to
solve a problem to meet a need and and
how do I take the full weight of
everything I've ever experienced um to
create that and and that's for me been
the key I focus on serving people I take
experiences and Imagination and
reflection and I just let that create
the incubator for what will come man
those four elements are extremely
poignant for genius content creation and
um you don't have to be able to
have the wherewithal to hop on a plane
to Copenhagen no I couldn't for decades
for sure that's my life now that's your
life now um but there's something
powerful in your yes and I think a lot
of people especially we're stuck to our
screens we're stuck to our home offices
there's a lot of Discovery to be had by
probably going outside can I give a
different illustration sure um I was in
my house I was going to the store and I
I saw this elder early couple in their
9s and they seemed disoriented they were
trying to get on a bus and one of them
dropped something and they were having a
hard time picking up their bag so I
pulled my car over incredibly busy
traffic and on Third and Fairfax and I
jumped out of my car and I helped them
pick everything up and I asked them
their names I asked them where they were
going they're trying to catch the bus to
get home and I said could I drive you
home and I put this elderly CLE who were
Jewish who' survived the era outside of
the Holocaust and and I'm driving them
to their home
experiencing the beauty and wonder the
suffering and sacrifice and resilience
of this of this couple I didn't have to
go to Copenhagen yeah I drove three
minutes from my house and I was having
this transcendently beautiful experience
when I dropped them at their house just
to see their gratitude um it just
overwhelmed me yeah and I don't think I
really told people about it at all it
just it but it's seared in my memory and
I'm so grateful for that moment and I
gave them my my number and they sent me
a text later thanking me and that's
happened over and over again I was at a
gas station with my wife I saw a guy his
credit card wouldn't work and he was so
frustrated and I said hey are you okay
and he goes just my credit card won't
work and I have to drive you know like
an hour and so I filled his car up with
gas and I um just said Thank you and
that guy somehow found me and sent me a
DM and started thanking me so much and
started telling me how his life had been
impacted by that and you have
serendipitous moments every day of your
life you don't have to fly to Amsterdam
if you can do if you can go to
Copenhagen awesome yeah but what I would
say is say
yes like say yes in life yeah when you
see an opportunity when you see an
opening when you know when you see
someone who needs your help just say yes
and watch how your life
changes man if we tap into our dominant
communication frequency and start
powering up all seven if we guard our
heart to protect from the shadow
frequencies um but also you have
empowered us today to be able to
recognize we can better tap into
experiences go outside help somebody
create new experiences that'll Empower
our
storytelling spark our imagination by
reading by watching by listening Empower
our reflection and I love that you
talked about love because one of our
core values that think media is that
love above all and we're talking to
Purpose Driven people because yeah when
we get in our own world and fight for
ourselves and the work quality goes down
but when it when we are servant leaders
creating content that solves problems
and thinking about that person we're
helping that person we're entertaining
that person we're impacting love just
infuses everything we're doing in
content Creation with a higher level of
power purpose and impact I could not
agree more and love is the driving
principle of the universe Yeah man so
powerful and you've added so much value
today and um grateful for you coming on
the podcast of course want to kick it to
you what else can people follow with
what you're doing and get engaged with
what you're doing mind shift the book is
out now and so we'll link that up in the
show notes but what else are you up to
and where can people follow you well we
have this fantastic um online Mastermind
called The Arena where we focus on
communication leadership character and
big ideas and it's um if if someone's
looking for a way to connect around the
world but they can't fly places and and
they can't afford an inperson Mastermind
this is I think the the future of
learning but if you just go to Irwin
mcm.com you can learn about the arena
you can learn about the conference we're
doing um next year already we just
finished the first arena live we're
doing we already have all of our
speakers for next year yeah which is
pretty amazing and and you can learn
about the books and everything else
we're
doing.com take media podcast uh
subscribe like share appreciate you
we'll see you in the next episode